前髪の犬じゃるな誰も見てねえだろうねこっちゃはじめしたらですだれかみてるよああ
ああ言うと今日はねちょっとね副音声なんで穴音が途切れなく説教は副音声でお楽しみ
くださいこちら
えっとの日の3番パウダーって有利の筋トレブーツですこれは5分でできるキーたぐっ
ちゃこれを持ってはこの筋トレずっと使ってですね
ドッパジャンプができるじゃなかったりこの橋の下で
俺はですねバッジジャンプをしたかったんですよ簡単にね
やってみたかったんすよでね今日はねこの柔らかいこのはこれは家ではでソフトタイプ
の8の日ば生んだ弦たくさん買ってくっつきましたそしてこうやって背中に背負ってね
こういうことでコーディくっつけて国家ラパン g ジャンポーシャひょっとしゃっ
ピョンでこう
売ってるって売ってるぎゃんじゃないかところがこういっておけるんじゃないかこっち
こそ太って書いてるからに柔らかい感じでですね愛されボディナディア
でもよれ
てみたいと思ってるんですよじゃあねやってるでしょ5ストレッチバッグを個々に装着
してそのまま飛び込みますここにくくりつけます走りついれるこのバントと僕を
くっつけてダイブしてきますはいこんな感じです
おっしゃー
準備ができたぞティガーいきます
ナータバッ
ちょっと思ってる強いんだけどね怖いよ
助けてっ
いきますではキントリグット使ったバンジージャンプやってみましょう
水に作成している前に座っておきます
間違いですまってこれさ金返って頭を打たない夜に行きます
j
ねっ待ってますじゃねぇ
大丈夫だよねー本当に怖いんだけどできます
普通バーン
はっはっは
あっはいあんな ak 部編
pou dou dou
事前に失敗だったねやっぱりソフトウェアは海からダメなんだと言って今回こちら
ハードを準備しました
今度はこのハードタイプで実際にあのあれでえっとあの
そこから更年んワンダー大丈夫ですっ
これでいいっこれいきますよたりすぎるんじゃないですかこれ
でもこんなんだよいけるかな
じゃあこれでやりましょう
あっはーいきます
ツリー2まあ
ダメですね
持っています